[Music]
car tester Michelle Assenmacher wants us
to know it's 30 degrees in sunny and she
has to work but working in a convertible
like this is almost like being on
vacation and this particular car is
almost like being on vacation in Italy
her mood improves with every kilometer
in Fiats new 124 spider a tribute to the
original spider that debuted over 50
years ago this new version merges
genuine roadster feeling with the
handling of a sports car Michelle sees
the spider is a real fun mobile it has
great pickup heads into curves
beautifully it looks nice and snappy at
103 kilowatts and 240 Newton meters of
torque
the Fiat specs don't really promise much
in the way of sporty driving but it's
top speed of 217 kilometers an hour
makes it quick as a flash firstly the
124 spider only weighs 11 hundred and 25
kilos so the engine has a fairly light
job secondly the car hugs the drivers
body tightly thirdly the seats are so
low and the cornering so stable that the
driving experience feels more intense
than in almost any other car of this
price range fourthly doing 150
kilometres an hour
whips just as much when through the
occupants hair as doing 250 in a Porsche
but this little race about reminds
Michelle of another roadster though not
from the outside without the Fiat logo
on the steering wheel she couldn't have
said for sure if she was driving a Fiat
124 spider or a Mazda mx-5 the
resemblance is not coincidental the
spider is built on the Mazda mx-5 s
platform but at least Fiat has its 124
spider bank in its range half a century
after rolling out the original what's
important is that an educated look says
Roadster and not mx-5 the horizontal
taillights long nose and curvaceous hips
with typical Italian flair the classic
silhouette is beefed up to athletic
proportions the dual exit exhaust
complete the sports car designed this
spider is more for fun than for carrying
people and cargo 190 kilos who are
allowed including driver and passenger
so the trunk only takes a meager 140
litres volume this often follows a
triangle eight centimeters tall Michelle
had to push the seat all the way back to
get comfortable but if the driver feels
squeezed in as a passenger well - and if
a tall person gets in and bends their
knees a bulge on center tunnel makes it
feel even more cramped the inside
reveals the spider and mx-5s common
basis both could use more legroom and
the seats feel tight in an already
fairly cramped interior and both cars
have four of their 9 Bose sound system
loudspeakers integrated into the
headrests the leather steering wheel is
standard the lusso equipment line we
tested includes air conditioning and
leather seats among other things the
seven-inch touchscreen rising from the
dash was also taken from the Mazda
[Music]
it only takes a poll and a push to put
the top up or back down in a few seconds
whenever desired and Germany the basic
model Fiat 124 spider lists at just
under 25,000 euros fun and fast times
come at no extra charge
[Music]
[Applause]